so I prepared for the podcast myself and
I've now got a guest ready to do the
conversation and I prepared them what do
people think recorded one two three four
episodes with recruiters and recruitment
business owners and what I wanted to
share was the feedback that I've
received now I'm really really pleased
about this because it just really goes
with why I started doing this so firstly
to whoever's listened to the podcast I'm
so grateful for your attention and
grateful for your time that you've taken
out of your day to listen to the podcast
so the people that have got in touch and
said what they thought or whatever is
that they've actually learned something
from it and that was my main my main go
if one person could listen to the
podcast and take something away from it
then I'm super happy and I've had a few
messages now that they've enjoyed the
conversation and enjoyed the layout they
enjoy how long it's gone on for and also
sort of what people are taking away from
it so I think listening to the feedback
that you get from doing your own podcast
is so important so whenever someone does
give me feedback the first question I
ask is how can I do it better is there
anything that you'd suggest so you can
use that feedback to them implement and
hopefully change things in the next
episodes etc so I just want to make a
very quick video to say thank you to
those that's listens and so far full
episodes in I've got some really good
feedback which I'm super super pleased
about and as I said I'm so grateful for
you guys for listening
[Music]